dans la province du cap la haute saison
pour les pommes et pour les pouvoirs se
termine habituellement plus de 20% des
poires sud africaines sont exportés vers
la russie
mais ces derniers fruits de saison
seront cette année écoulée à bas prix
sur le marché local personne pourtant ne
sait que faire de la majorité de la
production qui se trouvait déjà en mer
quand la guerre commencée
on estime qu'entre les pommes les poires
et les prunes plus de 800000 cartons
sont coincés en mer ou dans les ports
européens
faute d'avoir pu atteindre la russie
pour tous les fruits les gens se
précipitent pour trouver d'autres
marchés mais ils vont se retrouver en
europe avec un énorme surplus
en croire les experts les fruits risque
même d'être pourri avant de pouvoir être
consommée dans son bureau du cap le
ministre provincial de l'agriculture
cherche partout d'autres débouchés
southan morris export
certains de ces exportateurs ont déjà
décidé de dérouter les bateaux sur
rotterdam une partie de la cargaison
pourra être débarqués et même être
offerte à titre d' aide humanitaire en
pologne ou en ukraine
la guerre aura aussi un impact sur les
céréales 40% du blé consommer en afrique
du sud vient d'ukraine
les fermiers sud africains peuvent
essayer de planter plus de blé cet hiver
pour compenser le déficit mais il
explique que les récoltes reviendront
chez tout le monde dit que le prix du
blé va exploser les coûts de production
aussi augmentent
au profit des firmes
les coûts de production pourrait doubler
en raison notamment des engrais dont 90
% provenaient de russie toutes les
plantes seront donc affectés y compris
celles qui servent à alimenter le bétail
sur cette ferme depuis le début de la
guerre on a déjà eu un surcoût de 50
centimes par litre de lait
les agriculteurs sud-africain gère donc
la situation au jour le jour mais ils
sont convaincus que la guerre entre la
russie et l'ukraine aura un impact sur
leurs revenus comme sur ceux du
consommateur